third prize that was for the category of
most Innovative approach in an
established domain goes to Mr jasvi
datta and Mr shubham Kumar Masters in
bioinformatics and their project topic
was encyclical reverse mutation of Spike
protein RBD from different stars go to
Career host
with us
yes so thank you for giving me the
opportunity for participating in the
Home official Symposium post
representation competition and it is
good to get evaluate your research work
uh at this platform and I would also
like to thank my college faculty and my
fpi Mr Sandeep Sani for their constant
support so we worked on the structure
analysis part of SAS Cove to RPD protein
like spy protein and we try to do the
reverse mutation in our project and we
try to find them like how can the
mortality rate can be like get down and
what are the next uh
competition like uh what are the next
techniques which can be used for further
making the medicines in the field like
to get these SARS scope to down uh as a
pandemic
congratulations to you both how was this
experience developing your own project
meaningfully both
so uh we worked like uh we use multiple
tools for our project we used seven
tools for mutational analysis and then
we used uh different talking tools to
get our results for the protein protein
interactions and the structural analysis
was done in this whole project and it
was good to like complete whole project
in terms of structural analysis but in
bioinformatics
uh in addition to that we have also
we have also analyzed the phylogenetic
analysis of this our scope variants with
humans
fascinating stuff guys what are you
planning to do next
next um will generally try to pursue the
entity in structure biology or like drug
Discovery medicine Precision medicine
topics or the main topic would be a
aristobiology
so in these three failures will try to
pursue PhD
well thank you very much and again
congratulations most Innovative approach
is a really great award thank you
gentlemen